[Musique]
on entend souvent dire je ne réalise pas
de sécurité du logement
ces salles on voit ce quotidienne pour
des millions de personnes ont la
trouille du nombre de la caricature et
voix c'est nous 2011 aujourd'hui qui
cherchent un emploi
alors vous propose à nos parents de
travailler et qu'on n'est même pas
capable d'en garantir un revenu décent
parce qu'ils sont et ce qu'on essaie de
faire croire les sur le système des
retraites et que ce serait d'abord un
problème démocratique alors qu'on sait
tous que c'est d'abord un problème de
proportions entre ceux qui travaillent
et ceux qui travaillaient dans le dira
jamais assez mais n'y aurait pas deux
millions et demi de chemin on se posera
de même tout simplement parce que ils
devraient 2012 nous de toutes les
propositions de pension capitalisation
basse et l'insécurité la plus totale
c'est le contraire de la solidarité
entre parce que d'abord c'est le chacun
pour soi mais qui sait jouer au hockey
sans doute la bourse sont propres à me
confier l'argent des cotisations
sociales de millions de personnes à
quelques assureurs à quelques banquiers
ou qu'un seul réalisme est celui de
réaliser du pays
les retraites en chef c'est les
retraites participation qui consiste
bientôt la poste
les gens sont aujourd'hui c'est ma
marque fashion civilisation même la
nature aujourd'hui peut être acheté par
point d'étape nous on pense que la
protection de l'environnement
c'est contradictoire avec les rails au
problème c'est de savoir à qui on fait
confiance aux multinationales soient
population parce qu'ils sont loin d'être
maman leur a dit aux populations de
chalon le tunnel du mont blanc serait
sûrement par la première occasion de son
modèle radio population tourne le
chimique a toujours fermé à l'école avec
la nature c'est camille des cours d'eau
qu'on surveille des océans polaires
qu'on empêche d'être détruits de l'air
qu'on empêche d'être connue des rivages
on empêche d'être dépanné et surtout il
faut bien dire parce que ça n'est pas
l'écologie des guerres raison est autre
et qu'il faut abonnés ont accès à
internet
parce que des paysans sans terre bleue
porto allègre aux centaines de milliers
de jeunes qui étaient à gènes cet été
contre le sommeil
l'anxiété dans les rues barcelone
récemment contre sommet européen et la
volonté qu'un autre monde est possible
quand on voit qu'il ya quelques
multinationales pharmaceutiques
qu'impose un monopole carrément par des
sons sur l'accès à des soins pour des
maladies aujourd'hui nouvelle génération
qui veut que les multinationales arrête
de faire la loi
un autre monde est possible la prise de
conscience a lieu on peut changer
l'ordre des choses
ceci n'est pas un rêve car comme disait
baudelaire
pour ma part je quitterais s'en
retourner un monde dans lequel l'action
ne serait pas la seule
[Musique]
nos points communs qu'on a ici c'est
qu'on est tous révoltés et qu'on pense
que la société on peut toujours la
changer et l'autre point commun qu'on a
c'est que depuis cinq ans on se mobilise
les uns et les autres pour développer
des bagarres et des résistances face à
la droite donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
rassemblé que qu'on va essayer de
redonner la parole aux uns et aux autres
à la fois sur ce qu'ils ont fait et puis
sur ce qui reste à faire quoi
[Musique]
dans cette campagne on essaye de le
mettre sur leurs abonnés voit que j'aime
bien la droite lui aussi aujourd'hui on
vous voit la gauche sait les problèmes
d'insécurité et d'immigration et
beaucoup de responsables politiques qui
aimeraient que 2007 ce soit de nouveau
2002 et qu'on parle que d'un sécurité du
matin jusqu'au soir avec en plus une
variante sur l'identité nationale et
l'intégration la marseillaise le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge et compagnie alors que
la droite et l'extrême droite fasse ça
c'est pas franchement surprenant parce
que c'est un moyen ne pas répondre aux
questions sociales qui sont posées par
les mobilisations sociales dont on parle
depuis le début mai que ça vienne de la
gauche c'est quand même plus surprenant
quoi aujourd'hui on constate qu'un des
problèmes pour les retraites c'est que
déjà les fameuses annuités nécessaires
pour avoir une retraite à tout plat et
ben on est de moins en moins à pouvoir y
arriver et maintenant les retraités
c'est un des secteurs de la population
où on note l'apparition de deux poches
de pauvreté le minimum vieillesse
aujourd'hui c'est environ 620 euros par
mois donc c'est très faible et je crois
que la revendication d'une
revalorisation de 300 euros pour tous
est revenu c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est qui est très nécessaire dans une
grande entreprise comme la nôtre qui est
le quatrième constructeur mondial de
véhicules
eh ben on a des gens qui travaillent par
intermittence puisqu'on a eu l'exemple
de sandouville avec des gens qu'on lui
70 jours de chômage et qui fait
aujourd'hui bas effectivement ces gens
là ont un problème aussi de logements
puisque beaucoup de jeunes avaient pris
leur logement et leur indépendance qui
avait été embauché chez renault qui
aujourd'hui sont obligés de retourner
chez leurs parents avec des salaires de
misère parce qu'ils ont perdu en moyenne
depuis 2000 euros sur l'année dernière
sur les conditions de travail c'est vrai
pour les pour les plus anciens mais
c'est vrai aussi pour les plus jeunes
voilà au début on arrive dans un job ou
dans un boulot on fait le tout fou on
court après les heures sup
on essaie de de gratter le monde de
salaire avec des heures supplémentaires
et et puis au bout de dix ans on
commence à se dire que voilà la charge
de boulot est de plus en plus pénible
moi je travaille dans une boîte de
l'ascenseur on se fait deux trois mois
par an dans une chose une pente qui est
tout petit
pourquoi parce que les colis sont
carrées sont terriblement dégradée
notamment pression sur le travail la
sécurité au travail c'est deux morts par
accidents de travail par jour huit morts
par l'amiante par jour et ces morts là
on n'en parle jamais parce que sais-je
avec des prolos quoi sur les salaires on
a besoin aussi de
une représentation du mérite et de ce
que les gens donnent pour l'entreprise
et que si vous voulez encore faire
d'ironie 1500 euros bruts dans cinq ans
moi ça me va pas on n'a pas un point de
vue pleurnichard sur la société où on
demande simplement notre dû le respect
auquel on a droit puisque c'est 90% de
la population qui fabrique des biens des
richesses des services et qu'on voit
finalement jamais la couleur
aujourd'hui j'habite la banlieue
parisienne quand lé logement ils ont
augmenté quasiment de 50% en 10 ans et
les salaires ils ont augmenté de ce
fonds pour ça en disant que css c'est
vrai et je crois que le problème du
logement c'est aujourd'hui à un problème
fondamental et quand on est dans une
société où il ya des des centaines de
milliers de logements vacants et que par
ailleurs on a des gens qui dorment dans
la rue fait il ya quand même un truc qui
tourne pas rond quoi tout ce que vous
racontez à nous c'est notre avenir le
cpe ça a été la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase en plus de tout ça on
nous proposait de nous jeter à n'importe
quel moment comme un simple kleenex quoi
nous on pense que oui il ya un certain
nombre de mesures qui pour les jeunes
permettra d'améliorer notre notre
situation quotidienne que ce soit à une
allocation d'autonomie pour tous les
jeunes qui permettrait justement qu'on
ne soit pas obligé de tafer en plus en
plus d'aller encore un match et je
travaille 17h30 par semaine en plus de
mes 25 heures de cours au bout d'un
moment voilà quoi la semaine ça devient
compliqué pour effectivement des revenus
plus importants pour vivre mieux mais
quelque part effectivement l'on parle
beaucoup de
la petite enfance ou le quatrième âge
c'est à dire un certain nombre de
services publics à développer ou à
reconquérir il faut vraiment prendre les
services publics comme les garanties
garantie minimum est garanti quand même
qu effectivement on a tous accès quelles
que soient les territoires quels que
soient les âges quelles que soient les
professions au moins ou bien commun on
sait encore bagarrer dans un hôpital
récemment dans le service de psychiatrie
parce qu'il voulait supprimer encore six
postes et on s'aperçoit que bon toutou
les tous les points qui sont
intéressants vont vos privé et puis dans
le public on garde bien sûr toutes les
toutes les contraintes tout ce qu'elle
accueille 24 heures sur 24
toutes les urgences il faut entendre à
chaque fois la souffrance des soignants
qui disent on peut pas donner la qualité
de soins qu'on voudrait donner aux gens
et ça c'est vraiment insupportable
on est plus en plus nombreux à accepter
un minimum de serrer la ceinture
ce soit dans nos conditions de travail
que ce soit dans les baisses de
rémunération les blocages de
rémunération ou où les prestations
sociales qui diminue parce que le venin
qu'on nous dise tilt dans la tête c'est
le fait que la france s'appauvrit ray et
qui aurait plus les moyens finalement de
vivre correctement ni au boulot ni dans
la vie de tous les jours or voilà le
problème c'est que des richesses si on
n'a jamais eu autant en france qu'en ce
moment et la redistribution de ces
richesses l a jamais été aussi
inégalitaire qu'en ce moment on est
chacun dans notre coin ce soit au
service public dans le privé ou au
quotidien amener des bagarres un petit
peu séparément parfois tous ensemble
avec ou sans victoire une chose qui est
claire c'est quel que soit le
gouvernement qui sortira des urnes
les bagarres faudra continuer à les
mener donc ce vote pour nous c'est aussi
un encouragement aux luttes à toutes les
luttes qu'on a mené qu'on parlait à des
tas de personnes et celles qui devront
être menés dans les cinq prochaines
années
[Musique]